el 7 de agosto iván duque entrega las
llaves del palacio de nariño así fueron
los eventos clave que marcaron su
mandato tras poco más de un año de
llegar a la presidencia tú que hizo
frente a su primera gran crisis las
masivas protestas de noviembre de 2019
un indicio de lo que sería el estallido
social de abril de 2021 derivando en las
mayores manifestaciones en la historia
reciente de colombia la respuesta del
gobierno a una fuerte represión
5 mil 340 casos de violencia perpetrados
por la fuerza pública 40 homicidios y 35
casos de violencia sexual fue lo que
vimos durante tres meses una respuesta
al gobierno muy violenta una
criminalización de la protesta social
cuatro años en donde la violencia se
expresó con muchas caras unas derivadas
de las falencias en la implementación de
los acuerdos de paz 223 masacres sólo
entre 2020 y 2022 cerca de medio millón
de desplazados desde 2018 y más de 850
líderes sociales asesinados durante el
actual mandato según indepaz
precisamente por la no implementación
del acuerdo de paz comenzó a
recomponerse
la violencia dinámica de grupos armados
atentados contra líderes el cob en 19
acecho al país dejando 275 personas
fallecidas por cada 100.000 habitantes
la quinta tasa de mortalidad de la
región pero con un plan de vacunación
parcialmente exitoso 70% de la población
está totalmente inoculada la pandemia
también le marcó el pulso a la economía
del país y puso a prueba la respuesta
del gobierno muy bueno lo que pasó en
términos de la respuesta y las medidas
de política económica frente a la crisis
no tan bueno diría yo decepcionante lo
que pasó en términos de la expectativa
que iba a ser un gobierno reformista y
que iba a ser digamos una serie de
medidas para continuar impulsando el
crecimiento económico y la equidad la
frontera con venezuela otra protagonista
más de un millón de personas entraron a
colombia desde 2018 una afluencia masiva
hacia un país lejos de estar preparado
pero la respuesta del gobierno fue uno
de sus logros
yo quisiera destacar de este gobierno la
continuidad que se le dio al manejo del
tema migratoria que sin duda es una de
las políticas más ambiciosas en materia
de atención social a una población con
bastante necesidad lo que transita la
recta final de su mandato cargada de
obstáculos un paro armado a manos del
grupo criminal clan del golfo que afectó
a 11 de los 32 departamentos del país y
un índice de desaprobación que ronda el
65 por ciento